welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of venom
let there be carnage a film that further
ensnares eddie brock in stickier love
affairs that use way too much tongue i'm
not just talking about carnage oh
spoiler warning for the film's
post-credits scene venom's now getting
peter parker in on that action and i am
uncomfortable with it i'm gonna break
down all of the easter eggs and
interesting filmmaking details that you
might have missed in this film and by
the way the best way that you can
support what we do here at new rockstars
is by checking out our great merch
options like our latest venom let there
be carnage inspired design symbiotic
chaos at
newrockstarsmerch.com okay we opened on
the saint estes reform school in 1996
based on the saint estes home for boys
in the marvel comics the orphanage where
cletus cassidy lived as a kid and
allegedly burned down before becoming
the venom symbiote offshoot carnage and
first meeting spider-man in the ruins of
this building now in 1996 woody
harrelson was the 35 year old star of
kingpin and the people vs larry flint so
here playing the young cletus is actor
jack bendera but they still had woody
harrelson voice the character to open
the film with harrelson's iconic soft
indoor voice before we reveal the
character as an unhinged psychopath all
to ground cletus's priorities as his
romantic love for francis barrison aka
shriek the marvel villain who teams up
with carnage in the maximum carnage
storyline in the comics her character is
capable of releasing these powerful
sonic blasts which francis describes as
saying my mutations are advancing
previously the word mutant was somewhat
avoided at least in the mcu films but
now that marvel studios owns the x-men
ip and this movie with its post-credits
scene is linked with the mcu is just
another sign of how this is all
connected to a multiverse of marvel
characters where mutants can now exist
francis gets taken away escorted by the
young cop p mulligan later detective
mulligan whom she deafens in one ear as
he shoots her in the eye to create her
eye scar from the comics and she's taken
to the ravencroft institute the
superhero prison laboratory from the
marvel comics an east coast version of
which showed up in the amazing
spider-man 2 in 2014. she's overseen by
dr pazzo the name of a ravencroft doctor
whom carnage takes captive in the venom
carnage unleash series tom hardy returns
to eddie brock and the voice of venom
last seen in the 2018 film transitioning
from a star tv investigator to print
journalist interviewing serial killer
cletus cassidy and san quentin and now
we know his employer is the daily bugle
west coast edition since it is
headquartered in new york and it has the
same masthead as a version of the daily
bugle from the sam raimi spider-man
trilogy despite those movies having
their own eddie brock played by topher
grace but with the multiversal
implications of this movie's
post-credits scene those paradoxes
either don't really matter or are about
to matter a whole lot eddie and venom
feud with detective mulligan whom venom
nearly bites head off of actually later
mulligan's tussle with carnage and
shriek leaves his eyes glowing setting
him up as the future symbiote toxin as
mulligan becomes in the comics venom
begs eddie to play vigilante saying we
should be out there protecting the city
lethally setting up their reunion by the
end of this movie as the lethal
protector nodding of course the venom
lethal protector storyline that both
this movie and its predecessor are
inspired by in which eddie brock works
in san francisco and teams up with
spider-man as this movie's closed
moments hint will happen at some point
in the films eddie interviews cletus
again who tells him to print this
cryptic quote the distant cathedral is
all i see that fractured angel the other
part of me yeah this movie shows eddie's
investigative journalism into the mind
of cletus cassidy as a kind of goony
style treasure hunt with rhyming clues
and using the shape of a coastline as x
marks the spot and all this comes from
venom's photographic memory of the
carvings in cletus's prison cell which
venom redraws for eddie a way of showing
how venom's symbiote mind is far more
advanced than eddie's human memory is he
really needs him to be able to function
and the walls of cletus's prison cell
are covered with fun stuff like there's
a teddy bear his stick for yourself
torturing an animal in a cage it looks
like a figure holding a severed head the
words the phoenix will rise cassidy's
stick figure self with his hands up as a
gun fires a bullet that loops over his
head probably his own joke that the cops
never fully closed the case on all of
his murders and then this quote thus
strangely are our souls constructed and
by slight ligaments are we bound to
prosperity and ruin this is a quote from
mary shelley's frankenstein in which dr
victor frankenstein considers morality a
tight wire act as he stitches together
the body parts of dead criminals into a
reanimated corpse that goes on to
consider itself above the morality of
mankind reflecting cletus's arc in this
movie as a condemned criminal about to
be a corpse becoming a sort of
resurrected supernatural monster with a
hell of an ego and then on the other
wall of the cell there's clevis himself
in a cage above a tombstone that says
hell for vanished children similar to
the sign outside saint estes that's
marked home for unwanted children and
then there's a carving of the tree that
eddie later looks at on the sketch form
and then later finds on these grounds
with a different quote to the the stripe
was given between the suffering this is
a line from a poem called prometheus
from 1816 by english poet lord byron
which praises prometheus the titan from
greek mythology who stole fire from the
gods and gave it to the mortals which is
also a reflection of clevis's journey as
a deceitful mortal who steals the power
that came really if you think about it
from the heavens so the sketches take
them to rodeo beach in marin county it's
two miles north of the golden gate
bridge it's known for unique rock
formations on the coastline and here
they find more of cletus's victims
causing the governor to lift
california's moratorium on the death
penalty moratorium that our governor
gavin newsom ordered in 2019 in this
movie hints the governor did this to
boost his poll numbers maybe a nod to
the recent recall effort that newsom was
able to survive that i had to spend all
summer talking about to older relatives
in other parts of the country who were
like excited it might happen because
they all weirdly hate california but
joke's on them it rules here and we love
our rich history of infamous serial
killers and it turns out executing them
as mulligan reacts to this news in the
daily bugle in his office there's a
booking photo for e larson a nod to eric
larson comic book artist and writer from
the 90s spider-man era who went on to
co-found image comics eddie's apartment
is a mess it's covered in m m's for
venom's love of chocolate because this
movie says chocolate contains
phenylethylamine that they say is also
in human brains suggesting i guess that
chocolate is venom's anti-drug
replacement for eating human brains but
in actuality phenylethylamine when
consumed causes the brain to release
other chemicals so it's not in the brain
itself but i just think eddie might have
told venom this in order to get him to
stop eating people eddie also tried to
use chickens but venom named two of them
sonny and cher after the singing duo and
he's also got a tire chew toy that he
named snooki now when venom overtakes
eddie their new height punches a hole in
the ceiling and i like how you can
actually see past ceiling holes from
when this has happened previously they
returned to the bodega of mrs chen from
the first movie where venom adjusts on
the rack a publication bearing the
likeness of stan lee it even names him
on the cover calling back stan's cameo
as a dog walker in the previous film and
confirming that stan was just plain
himself venom takes the reigns and stops
them mugging leaving eddie dangling
while he gets a call from anne who tells
him that she needed some space after the
alien incident before referring to when
she turned into she venom in the 2018
film and she meets eddie in their old
favorite restaurant but now what was
previously a blue background lighting is
red reflecting carnage's growing
influence in eddie's life and shows
eddie the new engagement ring she got
from dan which eddie comments is so much
bigger than the one i got you and when
you actually compare the two side by
side dan got the more expensive flourish
of a double halo around the center stone
so truly it's just a cosmetically nicer
upgrade from eddie oh poor guy so venom
tries to cheer up eddie with a messy
breakfast while he plays let's call the
whole thing off from the 1937 gershwin
musical shall we dance it's a song about
a couple trying to work past her
differences and venom includes with all
the food a whole bunch of painkillers
which you'll notice eddie just keeps
lying around because obviously he needs
him venom also drops in the mail
including cletus's postcard with its
tiny tiny writing and venom asks eddie
if he's pen pals with an ant something
that eddie might now be able to do with
ant-man now that they're in the same
universe and both living in san
francisco but cletus wrote this letter
and it looks like in his own blood
saying every hero has an origin story as
he crushes a spider of course a meta
joke about how this isn't a spider-man
origin story actually venom and
carnage's origins in these movies have
been completely spider-less and only
after carnage's death does spider-man
into the picture we learn all about his
past as a child pushing his grandmother
down a flight of stairs as he does in
the comics but also executing his mother
with a hair dryer during a bath and his
father abusing him and so eddie visits
cletus during his final meal where
cletus calls him a cancer and venom
lashes out allowing cletus to bite eddie
on the hand actually the same way peter
parker got his powers except here it's
reversed with the biter getting the
powers and the way cletus sucked up that
spider as he crushed it on his hand here
as the blood wiggles on his finger he
slurps it all up actually in the comics
cletus and eddie share a prison cell and
there an offshoot of the venom symbiote
latches onto cletus turning him into
carnage that's why in this film the
carnage symbiote considers itself
venom's offspring calling him father now
if you stream or podcast or if you want
to sound good when you're gaming the
hyperx quadcast is the ideal standalone
microphone for you the quadcast comes
with anti-vibration shock mount to
reduce the rumbles of daily life and a
built-in pop filter to muffle pesky
plosives the led indicator lets you know
your mic status if it's lit it's live
you can also tap to mute
to avoid awkward broadcasting moments
it's got four selectable polar patterns
that allow you to instantly switch from
settings suited for streaming or music
or a conference call it's got a
convenient gain control dial to quickly
adjust your mic input sensitivity
the quadcast s model has cool looking
rgb lighting and dynamic effects that
are customizable through hyperx
ingenuity software it's super easy to
use and a great looking mic that also
really ups your work zoom game the
quadcast family is compatible with pc
ps5 ps4 and mac as well as major
streaming platforms like obs studio and
xsplit so you sound great to anyone
tuning in so head on over to hyperx dot
gg slash new rockstars or use the link
in this video's description to grab
yourself a hyperx quadcast mic and start
sounding and looking better eddie and
venom fight but i'm the only person that
took you in when your friends kicked you
off the planet ming-mong because you are
a reject yeah eddie says planet
ming-mong which in reality venom's home
planet is klyntar which is also the name
of a species vitum actually hints that
he's ready to share his hive mind with
eddie in the post credit scene but the
multiverse collision interrupts it or
might have caused it i go into that in
our post credit scene breakdown i should
check it out now director andy circus
broke this fight scene down for vanity
fair describing how they upgraded
venom's appearance from the 2018 film to
add some lick texturing around venom's
wide jaw and eyebrow bulges all in order
to give venom's face a more expressive
quality now circus obviously draws upon
his own extensive background and the
relationship between physical
performance and vfx animation from when
he brought to life gollum and snoke and
caesar for the planet of the apes
trilogy which are an amazing group of
films there you should check them out
and circus also revealed that tom hardy
pre-recorded all of venom's dialogue and
then would play it back in his ear so
that he could have the real argument
with venom's voice all going on in his
head if you look closely you can
actually see the earbud tucked way in in
his ear there also when venom breaks
eddie's nose and fixes it just so we can
break it again you can see where venom
resets that broken nose and the bruising
fades away right before he punches him
again this is just like how venom fixed
eddie's broken bones after the
motorcycle crashed in the previous film
now on the night of his execution cletus
quotes shakespeare's macbeth or
something
wicked
it's from act 4 scene one the second
half of a couplet spoken by the second
witch foretelling the arrival of the
morally corrupt macbeth actually the
full couplet is by the pricking of my
thumb something wicked this way comes if
you think about it cletus acquired his
powers by biting the fingers of eddie
leaving his own finger bloody and then
sucking it back up and is from his
fingers that the wicked carnage comes
carnage blocks the lethal injection and
transforms cletus's flesh his design is
sickening with pock marks on his tongue
to make him look all decaying also in
general a more slender build compared to
venom an ooze dripping off his tendrils
he's got a raptor like roar
and then a splash of black on his face
which i think is to link him to his
parents symbiote venom he attacks the
cell block using tendrils to stab and
hurl guards around he frenches one guard
and then he forms a big cyclone and when
they try to shoot him carnage opens a
hole in his chest to let the bullets
sail through meaning that for now at
least he and cletus do have a
functioning symbiosis their flesh is
infused one in the same cleetus dances
out of san quentin and sings and i'll
walk out a wiser stronger man mr warden
you taste just like ham which is a
parody of johnny cash's song san quentin
named after this prison and which the
normal lyric is and i'll walk out a
wiser weaker man mr congressman you
can't understand you'll notice during
this whole final act of the film eddie
wears the detroit lions jacket over a
mumford phys ed shirt which is an onto
another famous eddie eddie murphy in
beverly hills cop too venom intends a
rave with a cameo by rapper little sims
which becomes essentially venom's coming
out party he even says in his speech
that he has come out of the eddie closet
meanwhile cletus suits up in a new look
and steals a car and then uses carnage
tendrils to hack the internet which is
an odd to carnage infamously snaking
into a computer and using the internet
to invade the homes of his prey in the
comics one of the really crazy things
that he does and then back at the
ravencroft institute there is another
inmate there named siegfried i looked it
up there's not a prominent siegfried in
the marvel comics other than a kind of
obscure antagonist to dum-dum dugan in
the old search and fury comics i don't
think this is him which is kind of a
missed opportunity like he could have
thrown a rhino in there you know but
carnage breaks into shriek's confinement
and uses his tendrils to hug her cell
and crushes it to bring them into an
embrace and they escaped in this red
convertible woody harrelson definitely
giving off some natural porn killer
vibes here meanwhile venom collapses in
mrs chen's store via drunk partier and
oozes out of them and later overtaking
his chin base to ann and dan in the
funniest scene in the film shriek tries
to find eddie at his place and sees a
photo of anne and then goes after her
and dan all so that they can have guests
to their red wedding and at one point
and once again becomes she venom to
break eddie out of custody and the
wedding goes down in grace cathedral
similar to carnage's church setting in
the final level of the maximum carnage
video game and venom sees carnage for
the first time oh [ __ ] that is a red one
now don't be too hung up on the color
here it's not like there's a yoshi color
coding system the symbiote hierarchy
venom is just recognizing that carnage
is more intertwined with cletus's actual
blood which freaks him out because he's
been having some insecurities about his
own level of symbiosis with eddie
cartage bites off the head of a priest
that they brought there to officiate the
wedding saying power up using him to
grow so i guess clergy is symbiote
superfood and one point carnage looms
over venom framed in the stained glass
which the director called an homage to
the leonardo da vinci vitruvian man
sketch which da vinci drew to suggest
intelligent design in the ratios of
human anatomical structure the fact that
carnage is crudely recreating this is
just another example of his let there be
carnage ego he considers himself a god
embarking upon his own genesis the dawn
of a new era but the battle turns when
carnage tries to kill shriek because he
hates her sonic blasts he's pissed off
that she cares about anne's life and
that turns cletus against carnage and
proving to venom that they do not have
the true symbiosis that he thought they
did at one point anne falls and she's
framed in venom's eye very similar to
the shot of spider-man's loved ones fall
in his eyes mary jane in the first rainy
film and gwen stacy in the maze and
spider-man 2 shriek gets back at carnage
by blasting the bell detaching
everybody's symbiotes and collapsing the
tower as well as the bell entry and
venom's able to gobble up carnage
actually just as he does at one point in
the comics and he bites off clayton's
head dropping this unfortunately rated
pg-13 movies one f-bomb now in the
aftermath eddie talks about cervantes
don quixote quoting facts are the enemy
of truth lamenting that despite he and
venom aspiring to be lethal protectors
and factually serving the public good by
disposing carnage the truth that society
will only be able to see are them as a
monster and that distinction between
facts and truth gets further warped in
the film's ending after a great closing
shot showing the two runaways on a
mexican beach finally giving venom that
sand in his toes and wind in his hair
that he had always wanted a post-credit
scene where venom offers to open eddie's
mind the symbiote hive mind a hint that
we might actually meet the klintar
society in venom 3 but then these two
are suddenly transported to another
reality that of the mcu with venom
reacting to j jonah jameson's report on
peter parker probably the aftermath of
doctor strange's spell in spider-man no
way home with which venom is rumored to
appear in and this makes venom
officially part of the mcu now i did
break down this scene and its
implications to no way home and the
whole mcu multiverse going forward all
in another video but i love that this
film ends in this place of facts versus
truth because eddie brock and peter
parker now have this in common as two
misunderstood vigilantes battling that
false truth of the world seeing them as
psychopaths i think it gives them a
common cause to fight as fellow lethal
protectors in a world where reality
cannot be believed however we must
remember that cervantes don quixote ends
with them burning the books because
coyotes fantasies are destructive
inferior to the real world ultimately i
think that's where peter parker will end
up choosing to live with his
uncomfortable reality and reject the
allure of an impossible dream you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow and subscribe to new
rockstars for breakdowns of everything
you love thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you